President Trump is warning China not to
retaliate for the newest tariff hike on
its imports three days ago the president
raised tariffs to 25% on approximately
200 billion dollars on Chinese goods
Beijing has promised to take necessary
countermeasures mr. Trump fired off a
series of tweets this morning he says
you asked companies and consumers should
not pay the tariffs they should buy from
a non-tariff country or from a US
company the president's chief economic
advisor Larry Kudlow admitted yesterday
Americans will be affected by the
tariffs both sides will pay and these
things and of course it's a tariff on
goods coming into the country the
Chinese aren't paying no but the Chinese
will suffer GDP losses and so forth with
respect to a diminishing export market
and goods that they may need for their
own but the president says China doesn't
that China it pays the tariffs they may
suffer consequences but it's US
businesses and US consumers who pay
correct yes to some extent yeah I don't
disagree with that Jill Schlesinger is
with us Jill good mom so let's just
button this up here the president has
said the Chinese will pay these tariffs
and it'll go right to the Treasury is
that the way tariffs work no so the way
it works is that the importer the u.s.
importer pays the tariff so who is the
importer a retailer a wholesaler a
manufacturer of other products and what
usually will happen is or what has
happened is they'll absorb some of that
fee in terms of lower margins or they'll
increase prices to consumers and so it's
some combination of that the problem
with these new tariffs is many of these
folks who are the importers cannot
absorb a 25% tariff they will likely
pass a lot of that on to consumers and
so what are we as a consumer out there
what are we paying more for okay
Furniture is a big one building supplies
is a big one shampoo dog collars I mean
it goes dog colors Nora and I are very
upset about this baseball mitts
backpacks luggage leather handbags the
fabric that goes into fleece there are
thousands of items on this list and
you know if you like your some of the
food that comes in beets carrots kale
they it's just like an enormous number
of products that could be impact how
quickly will we see those prices
increase well you know some people are
saying it's just a few weeks I'm hearing
more like 90 days 90 to 120 days because
again the tariffs went into effect 12:01
Friday did not impact anything that was
already enroute here of course there are
previous tariffs that people have been
paying higher prices for already is it
realistic for the president to say and
this is a shift we should note today
before he'd been saying Chinese are
paying to Treasury now he's saying
moving past that and saying well you
should just buy from other countries or
US goods that are made here is that
possible well I think we should look at
the example of washer and dryers there
was a tariff put on washers last year
and the average washing machine went up
by eighty six bucks both domestic
produced and the ones that were imported
also dryers went up by ninety two
dollars there was no tariff on a dryer
so what we know is that US and
international manufacturers use the
opportunity to Jack prices on both types
of goods everyone better be making more
money because these things are going to
cost us more money will be my trademark
advantage people are taking advantage of
a situation absolutely
which is why free marketeers and
conservatives have been against these
tariffs in the past yep law of
unintended consequences things will rise
alright Jill Schlesinger thank you so
much